hey everyone it's emery i'm going to be
taking you through
my beauty look for beauty spire whilst
answering some of your questions
now my eyebrows are my most important
thing that i've ever
loved in my life because they're still
growing out
see they're all growing out the side i
have to fill in the bits here
at the beginning and um i use nyx
professional makeup
brow tint pen and i just feel like it's
the easiest thing to use
and you can literally draw on the
tiniest lines
i try and draw it on very naturally
really this which is the biggest change
from when i was a teenager
i've been stepping up my comfort zone
and using really bright colors
and these i've found are amazing because
they're
actually as bright as they look this is
the nyx professional
makeup liner stick epic wear they
last forever i use my fingers a lot
don't judge me
look at that right this dries really
quickly so you have to like
blend it in asap and then um
do a little bit of green on the inside i
feel like green and pink is like my
favorite thing lately
this is the next professional makeup
ultimate shadow palette
and i'm just gonna add a little bit of
oomph
i should get a brush really i'm gonna
get a brush look how bright that is and
i can feel it sticking to the
pencil underneath okay now that our eye
and then i finish it off with nyx
professional makeup on the rise mascara
i do curl my eyelashes before as well
i'm going to put on a pink t-shirt and
pink trousers
and pink coat
[Music]
my biggest beauty indulgence
has to be laser hair removal
and it's the best decision i've ever
made shaving
really annoys me i just find it
so inappropriate it always happens
to be that i notice that i've got hairy
legs when i'm wearing
go to wear a dress for something or it's
just
it's just annoying and quite time
consuming
to shave it might not be for some people
but for me
it's ag and deciding to
get it all off and never get back again
is a brilliant decision that i've made
my daily
must-do beauty ritual is
whack this on skin food will either
i tell everyone about this every single
person i meet
i tell them and then they come back to
me and they say
that it's the best supposed to be mainly
very dry areas but i use it everywhere
now i rarely wear perfume really
but if i do it is this
la vie est belle la via belle pierce i
don't know how to pronounce it
i think that means life is beautiful i
used to walk past this smell when i
worked at ted baker
when i was younger passed all the
fragrance section
it just caught my nose every time and
since then i haven't really bought any
other scent so
this is what i smell like if you ever
wanted to know
the thing i love most about having pink
hair
is that it's just different to the norm
i've always loved experimenting with my
hair colors
ever since i was young i've had crazy
hair like
green blue purple red brown black
brown isn't that crazy but um yeah all
different hairstyles
and i just feel like it's how i express
myself i
i'm quite crazy inside so i want to
replicate the outside and pink
seems to suit my skin color quite well
so i actually i think it suits quite a
lot of skin color as well pink hair to
be honest
so if you want to try it try it out my
favorite wellness rituals
include growing my own vegetables and
that is
an accomplishment when you get your
first vegetable
or fruit or whatever you feel so good
but then also you can eat it after and
you feel like it's really fresh and
hasn't got any
crap on it and also collecting crystals
trying to meditate um
mindfulness in general when i'm having a
cup of tea
i create my perfect skin finish
probably with this highlighter this is
beauty light wand
by um charlotte tilbury and i just
put it here and on the tip of my nose
i don't know why i did that actually to
be honest it looks a little weird
but i normally put it here and here and
sometimes just on the top
of my lip there i always feel like when
you look like
you've got growing skin as you is when
you look
healthiest and young and fresh
you can never have um too shiny skin
my favorite going out outlook as of now
seems to be a really heavy eyeliner
which is
something i steered very clear of for a
while
i'm going through it again so massive
eyeliner
dark lip some people say you either do a
extravagant eye or extravagant lip but i
like to see both
so i've been doing karate since i was
nine years old i love it so much
loads of reasons why really but mainly
when i was younger it
took my mind off of other things and i
was quite
naughty as a child and
couldn't hold my attention i still can't
really hold my attention on things for
too long but
it was one thing that i could really
focus on and i learned a lot about
discipline there it let me get my anger
out
so it was a great outlet for that so
i've been on a massive journey
of my own mental health and that's
really thanks to other people talking
about it to be honest because
i have actually struggled for so long
and i never knew what was going on until
i saw someone talking about it
on twitter or on the tv or in an
interview or ted talks or something so
i owe it to other people for opening
my eyes to my own brain that's why i
talk about it because
other people talking about it helped me
also during
lockdown in 2020 i started seeing a
therapist
and she has honestly changed my
entire life everything is better now
some people
i guess haven't got the means to or
haven't got access to
therapy so i'd say just
tell anyone how you're feeling like tell
your friend tell your parents
tell a piece of paper tell
twitter honestly just write down
and say how you're feeling out loud and
it just
lets it off your mind a little bit more
the biggest thing i've learned
is that all of the problems that i have
are because of something else i've
learned about
my confidence and my anxiety my social
anxiety is from stuff that i experienced
when i was younger so
it's really hard to give tips on people
on how to deal with it because it always
down to something else that you've
experienced in your life
as soon as you acknowledge a feeling
then you can work on it and change it
instead of pushing it to the side and
saying i'm fine i'm fine i'm fine
just be open to the thought of maybe not
being okay and that's fine that you're
not okay
start a journey of loving yourself
and then everything else in life will be
better
you are important you are the focus
focus on yourself
love yourself and then live your life my
favorite beauty hack
that i've picked up lately i actually
saw this girl doing it
on tik tok of her doing face yoga
so every morning probably not every
morning but i try and wake up put a
youtube
video on and
do things to my face and it wakes me up
and makes me look better it's hard to
pick a favorite hair
for me because i get so bored so quickly
that i can switch from one to the other
i guess right now
is this short bob come to terms with a
short bob
not being boring i used to think i'd
want
the long hair and the crazy hairdos but
i think also because it's pink when it's
short
it doesn't look boring and you could do
so much of it i always
switch it up i mean like today i've got
these little clips in but that is
because i haven't washed it in two weeks
but
i can go through stages next week i'll
probably have hair extensions in
and have it really long down to my bum
top tips for doing
your hair yourself is to always make
sure
that you put a mask on your hair to help
it
come back to life because i bleach my
hair a lot
so it's getting damaged quite a lot all
the time
this is the one i use um moroccan oil
restorative hair mask this one
i bought this purely because of what it
smelled like on my friend's hair
she was standing next to me and i
sniffed her hair for about five minutes
so it got me because of the smell first
and
and obviously it helps my hair a lot
yeah after every bleach i
make sure i whack this on make sure you
wear a really old jumper or
t-shirt that you do not care getting
messy um put towels everywhere
um make sure you condition your hair
before
or wash out any color that you have
before i
try and be quite professional when i
like
have the little brush thing but most of
the time i just work it in and
make it all go like that but it is
hard it's hard to do it yourself but
this one this is a washing wash out
color
crazy color and it's called a candy
floss
so if you want this hair color go get
that
so here are a few of my favorite
products
that i use and the first thing is this
kate somerville
um spf 50. now this is so cool because
it's a spray
and the other ones that i've used before
a lot a cream and you put them on
obviously before your makeup and i
always feel like
it makes my makeup look funny and this
one you can put on before or
after because it's a setting spray as
well and it's
so sick and it smells amazing
so yeah this is a yes
obviously we'll eat a skin food this is
almost
empty i need to get some more this is
incredible
and i love having dewy skin so
it's quite thick just so you know this
i use as foundation
just lovely really just love it so there
you go
they are all my favorite products
and stuff that i just love to do and
obviously experimenting with different
makeup still
so i'm new to this game um
i'm loving it and i hope you enjoyed it
hope it wasn't too boring
and thanks grandma for having me hope
you
took some good stuff away from that and
try some of the stuff
out and let me know how it goes for you
bye
you